FEMA administrator Brock long joins us
now from Washington DC with the latest
on the federal government's response
good morning administrator let me ask
you this hurricane is strong and it is
big and I was looking at some of the
data that less than 50 percent of the
people under mandatory evacuation orders
actually heed that call is this a
life-threatening storm yes ma'am it is
it's not a question of if Florence is
going to impact the Carolinas in
Virginia it's going to and it's going to
be a devastating storm this reminds me
I'm a North Carolina native I grew up in
Newton North Carolina in 1989 Hurricane
Hugo the last landfall in category four
storm into the Carolinas came right over
my house we were out of power for ten
days I was out of school if I remember
two weeks and so this storm is setting
up to be very similar to that one so
we're really hoping that people will
heed the governor's warnings in South
Carolina North Carolina and Virginia
today and make sure that you're taking
proper precautions to get out of the
storm surge areas and into facilities
that can withstand the winds and then
the National Hurricane Center is warning
that this storm is going to linger once
it hits how does that affect FEMA's
response yes ma'am so this is going to
be a marathon event this is not going to
be a quick hit across the coast and
let's keep in mind that hurricanes can
impact the entire States and we're
looking at not only coastal impacts from
cat four storm surge and high winds
making landfall but as this system comes
inland its projected to stall out which
means copious amounts of rainfall
through the Carolinas into Virginia as
well as many of the mid-atlantic states
so we're positioning from basically
South Carolina to Delaware as we speak
to be able to support our state partners
and administrator long there's also the
fact that this area's been soaked so far
this year how does that affect things
like trees weakening and falling stuff
that people might not recognize when
they think of a hurricane yeah you're
exactly right unfortunately the remnants
of Gordon passed through this weekend
the mid-atlantic states dropping a lot
of rain fall which saturates the rivers
so the question is how much more
rainfall can these rivers rivers handle
and right now you're seeing forecasts of
30 inches or greater I'm truly worried
about North Carolina Virginia
particularly the central and western
portions of those states
haven't seen this type of rainfall in a
long time see many people got smacked
last year Broca's you know with
hurricane urban Hurricane Maria what
lessons did you all learn from that well
I think the nation learned a lot it
takes more than FEMA to appropriately
respond and recover and emergency
management's like a chair with four legs
it takes the federal government that's
one leg it takes the state and local
government that's the other leg it takes
the private sector and non-governmental
organizations that's the third leg and
then it takes you the citizen as the
fourth leg and when all four of those
legs go into a response and recovery the
chairs stable emergency management does
its job collectively it's a whole
community event one of the things I like
to remind citizens is that citizens are
the true first responder for any small
emergency to the large disaster and we
depend on people being prepared and we
don't have a real culture of
preparedness in this country that we've
got to work on and again you say people
take this very seriously yes yeah yeah
yeah look this is a cat for storm
potentially a cat five at FEMA we always
plan for one category higher this is
nothing to play with you're going to see
massive amounts of storm surge along the
coast which is the primary driver of
evacuations and then this system is
going to come in and cause devastating
inland floods statewide across South
Carolina and North Carolina and Virginia
administrator Brock long we thank you
and everyone at FEMA for all that you do
thank you thank you I appreciate it